[Music]
hello i'm ann jones the abc's nature
nerd and today we're breaking down
videos of the world's cheekiest urban
animals
but
city living isn't for everyone some
animals do make a go of it what
sometimes they act in curious and
bizarre ways from learning new tricks
to mindless games
could all of this weird behavior
actually be a sign of something more
i've been trawling the internet for the
best animal videos to decide once and
for all which of these city animals is
truly extraordinary
[Applause]
you may have heard them tippy-tapping
across your roof or
they might be in your garden eating the
tops off your carrots but one thing's
for sure possums are a little bit
naughty by nature and that's why they
end up on the internet
[Music]
yes
come on
come on
greg did she just call it greg
greg
this way
let's look a little bit like a greg
it appears that this lady is trying to
lure greg outside with a piece of white
bread that's not a very effective
strategy
[Music]
[Laughter]
the possums in australia that we have in
our backyards they're actually quite
territorial if you're seeing a possum on
your roof it's probably the same possum
that you're seeing every single night
oh
oh dear
i think that the possum is making itself
look big
and getting ready to defend itself
from the dog it looks slightly as if it
should be in manpower australia
but
i'm here for it
that's amazing it's using its prehensile
tail as well to provide an extra grip so
it's really gripping on it's got the two
back feet with the toes completely
stretched out and its tail wrapped
around
[Music]
oh a little baby
not so little baby trying to get into
the pouch really
so like a kangaroo has a pouch so do the
possums and their babies are also called
joey's which is
super adorable they're born really
quickly after conception it only takes
17 days or something for the little pink
wriggler to make its way up outside the
mother and into the pouch that's one of
the speediest pregnancies in the whole
animal kingdom
children eh she's like why did i do this
they said it'd be easy
[Music]
okay
okay
where it was just a candy bar
oh my god what
is that oh you see it
it's a squirrel where
it's
is
it's him creating all of the havoc not
whatever animal has inside there i'm
guessing that this is an opossum at
least not one of our possums because
they are only in our region of the earth
oh god now they've got the police
involved law enforcement
for a possum
no there we go he's done it before
scooped it out
opossums are the only marsupial in north
america which is very cool and the
possums in australia they're marsupials
as well but
our ones are probably closer related to
like kangaroos because they split off so
long ago and they do sort of look the
same but they are very different i mean
this one's got makeup on that makes it
look like it's in kiss
[Music]
oh skunky
so it looks like we're on night vision
here
here comes opossum
yes
[Laughter]
costumes are jerks drink drink drink
drink drink oh
yeah then just
look at the proper draggled skunky
oh
ah no
why would you do that there is a defense
mechanism that opossums are capable of
and that is sort of like pretending to
be dead their heart rates slow down
their respiration slows down they will
expel a green liquid out of their butt
and interestingly this catatonic state
isn't something that's controllable by
the o possums it happens like the fight
or flight mechanism happens and it
appears that that's happened
now
i mean you're probably just further
distressing the animal also
don't pat wild animals
thank you
so possums and opossums are not the same
creatures but they are pretty
extraordinary they're mischievous wild
animals that have had to adapt and they
have some incredible ways of finding a
foothold in our cities
[Applause]
squirrels you probably see them
scurrying around northern hemisphere
parks but is there more to these little
guys than meets the eye
looks like it's up like 10 stories or
something it looks really high
wow that's really cool so it seems to be
able to grip onto
lots of different surfaces including
that brick
really easily
no way
[Music]
oh my god
so
did it survive
they think so
so squirrels do really big leaps and can
actually survive falls that
almost no other creature would be able
to survive and apparently the reason is
is that they're so light and they have
this ability to make themselves pretty
flat so instead of falling with a thud
like you and i would they have the
ability to sort of pad themselves in the
air i suppose so yeah it is conceivable
that it would survive that if it didn't
impale itself on a stick i suppose
no
fight i'll take you
[Music]
so a lot of this it's like west side
story about the squirrels a lot of it's
fought in song so there's lots of
talking to each other and only a little
bit of biffo by the look of it squirrels
in any one local area probably do have a
bit of a hierarchy i mean the bigger and
older you get and especially if you're a
male that means you're going to be
dominant and maybe this is a couple of
youngins trying to sort out their place
in the hierarchy and also eat as many
sunflower seeds as squirrelly possible
[Music]
so the squirrel is putting the nuts into
cheek pouches it's not putting them into
the mouth it's like a separate little
anatomical skin pouch that goes in the
side
it can fit a lot of nuts in there and
he's absolutely stuffing himself
i love the sound it makes
must be a dentist nightmare
squirrels if you go even further up the
family tree are rodents so they're in
the same family as rats one of the
things that they have in common is the
fact they've got teeth that keep on
growing so how many has it got in there
now it's like six or seven
[Music]
eight
and he's gone thank you goodbye
sucker for a fluffy tail
squirrels are coming to this doorway
because they clearly know that there's
going to be food at this doorway i mean
look at them it's like drive-by service
yeah i'll have a peanut yeah thanks okay
bye it's thought that some squirrels
could squirrel away
something like 10 000 nuts
for their winter they can lose something
like a quarter of their cage to other
squirrels or birds nicking their seeds
and nuts right
so they've got strategies to manage that
and organize their buried treasures they
call it chunking and basically they put
the really good nuts of one species over
there and a different species over there
and another thing that they do if they
know that another girl is watching them
they make an elaborate display of
digging
and putting a nut in and putting it back
and then they go and bury it somewhere
else
[Laughter]
so there are gliding squirrels or flying
squirrels but they're not really flying
they have a potato
which is a big bit of skin that goes
from their front leg to their back leg
and when they stretch it out
they create a little squirrel suit like
you might see those fancy skydivers
wearing very cool little critters
i love that it launches itself and you
can see its tail acting like a bit of a
rudder these little guys can do
something like 45 meters in one glide
which is pretty substantial considering
you like that big
[Music]
squirrels are aerodynamically gifted i
think we can all agree on that and that
means that they're really good at living
in our cities where we create lots of
vertical environments for them to thrive
i don't think we can say that they're
extraordinarily smart but they are
extraordinarily cute and that goes a
long way in this world
[Music]
in australia these guys are probably the
worst neighbors you could imagine
they're really loud they rip apart your
house and they're basically obnoxious
but
could all of this behavior in cockeys
actually be a sign of intelligence
[Music]
this is my day right now
oh look at these little tootsies this
cocky has just flown over don't no no no
it's already stolen my eerie hi
hi
this is what he did to it oh
all the hallmarks of a bird that's been
fed in the past
oh that's coming in it's going to hijack
that car what is it don't
it gives you a really good view of its
feet
like all parrots they've got two toes
going forward and two going back this
gives it an incredible amount of
dexterity when it wants to grasp stuff
it's like a bat
if you imagine a human bite to be like
120 psi it said that the cocky can bite
like
350 psi it's like three times the
strength of our jaws in that little beak
this is like one of my favorite things
in the world cocky's on bins which
sounds really weird
someone's put big heavy rocks and a
brick on top of their bin in an attempt
to make it too heavy for the cocky to
lift
here we go pushes off
yep yep you got it a little bit more
yes
and then the little shuffle
uses one hand
and it's beak
so cool
[Laughter]
the researchers have been able to verify
that cocky's watch each other and this
could be an example of cultural
transmission that means that over time
they're passing knowledge from one bird
to another so these cockies are smart
very smart i would definitely employ one
oh
hello here comes someone cheeky
oh
definitely trying to be dominant and
playful the crest is up
[Music]
why are they such
[ __ ]
sulfur crested cockatoos have really
complex social hierarchies and
that means that some of this play fits
into that
hierarchy business
imagine having a designer cat like that
and then having a cocky harassing it
that's australia nature bites back
because of their amazing intelligence
and behaviour cockatoos are actually
pretty popular pets i got to speak with
a very special cockatoo called bentley
and her human kristin
hi bentley say hi
bentley has the intelligence of a human
toddler you really have to have a lot of
patience a lot of toys they need to
forage to keep themselves active and
healthy oh all right
this is what i go through all day long
what a cutie
well as you can see cockatoos are
extremely mischievous and she's really
not for everyone but she's the perfect
companion for me
we just we do everything together it's
obvious how much joy bentley brings to
kristen's life and probably vice versa
that cockatoos are not easy pets so if
you think that a parrot might be your
next best friend the best thing to do is
check your local guidelines and make
sure you're not doing anything illegal
or immoral because remember you're
basically talking about a toddler here
[Music]
so this is obviously a pet cockatoo
and parrots are apart from humans the
only animals that have been documented
to spontaneously dance there are palm
cockatoos up in the northern bit of
queensland which can drum and they drum
their own rhythms it's generally the
males and they're doing it to try and
attract a female sort of like what we do
when we're on the dance floor trying to
attract a mate
[Music]
that was me trying to attract me
[Music]
oh we got an angry cocky here
looks as if there was a goanna up that
tree goannas and snakes are actually a
danger to cockies just not really when
the cocky is in its adult form it's more
about going in stealing eggs and eating
them or fledglings or little baby birds
i'm surprised the person has remained
close enough to film this
because the noise
the noise
when they're upset even when they're not
upset
oh
if you see a picture of the sound like
the sound made visual they take up like
all of the frequencies it's horrendous
for your ears but it's really effective
for them it means that they can be heard
over really long distances and that's
really important when you're a highly
social animal
[Music]
so yes cockeys are amazing creatures
they're clever and capable and
even though they can be annoying if you
do keep your property secure and your
food secure i do not feed them they can
be brilliant neighbours because you get
to watch them playing all the time
[Music]
get out of there
[Music]
[Applause]
next up we've got monkeys
their ability to outsmart tourists gives
them a level of street cred that i get
nowhere near
you might not know just how brilliant
monkeys are unless you spend any time
with them or if you watch some videos on
the internet
[Music]
oh wow it's got a bike
and a dog
it's riding a bike i mean he's got the
seat right down like a true dmx bandit
wait he's [ __ ] i would hazard a guess
that that is not a wild monkey oh it
does have a collar on i just saw it
there okay yeah monkeys are kept as pets
all over the world with varying levels
of legality so this looks like a
long-tailed macaque i think this is an
old world monkey that means that it's
sort of genetic lineage comes from the
monkeys from um africa rather than from
uh america right and generally they
prefer to get around on like all fours
so by sort of sitting itself up and
actually balancing on two wheels is
pretty freaking cool
okay you have a whole bunch of booms
inside this house
check it out baboons
home invasion
wow there's like five of them just
streaming out of that window
there's lots of this what we call human
wildlife conflict in south africa in
particular around baboons because their
home habitats have been basically
destroyed they've moved closer and
closer into human habitation come on get
out of here get out of here get out of
here
oh you're gonna want more than a broom
out the door that baboon has a potential
there to feel very cornered and a
cornered animal is a dangerous animal
yeah that's all out that door i'm gonna
i'm gonna step out for a second you just
take care so that's a warning bark it's
quite forceful like that sounded pretty
loud especially in that small
environment but baboons have all sorts
of sounds that they make because they're
really social and it often follows that
if you're a social species in general
you have lots of ways of communicating
with each other
so baboons they're really big you
wouldn't want to wrestle with one and
they are definitely smart they know that
if they go into houses they're going to
get yummy food and that's why they're
there there we go he's out who's out
mission accomplished i mean guys you're
not that victorious they still trash the
house
it's a cutie
okay this one looks like it's in bali
there's lots of monkeys that live around
the temples
he knows how to open the camp
so smart
it's gonna go up your nose mate
see he's having trouble getting the lips
around the edge of the bottle
how it's learnt to undo the bottle and
drink from it i don't know exactly but
it is phenomenal the best thing about
that video is the fact that it drinks
like with its little finger up
so posh
[Music]
okay
wow look at this
don't think it was stuck it was trying
to avoid the humans that were down below
yeah that's a really high jump
but that's what you do when you think
your life is in danger
so
this monkey is
stressed i suppose there's heaps of
other ways to put its in distress that
means that it's got a feeling within its
body it's going to act in irrational
ways just like we do when we get
stressed in fact researchers have found
that monkeys are capable of all sorts of
complex emotions just like us
[Music]
that's a huge jump
so powerful got really powerful back
legs so that it can spawn that's the
official turn
i mean that's several times it's body
length they
can jump much much further than humans
can
in comparison to our body lengths
they land so beautifully as well monkeys
like these spend about half their time
going from tree to tree often from
canopy to canopy without going down to
the ground so when they bring that skill
set to the city it works really well
especially because in modern cities we
tend to use lots of vertical space so as
we go up so will the monkeys
so now you know urban monkeys are really
extraordinary they're emotional
intelligence their problem-solving
capabilities means that they make
interesting neighbors in our cities
even if we have to watch our backs
[Music]
crows get a bad rap for centuries
they've been associated with death and
decay and bad omens but really are they
all that scary or are they just scary
smart
[Music]
how you doing say hello
so beautiful hey hello hello
hello
wow how are you
how are you
how are you
that that
was amazing
it was like pitch perfect i know right a
lot of snow i know
i know right i know
he's sick of the conversation though
ravens uh and crows are absolutely
amazing among the most intelligent
beings on the planet
some behavioralists say that they're
like feathered primates they can be
taught to count up into a limit and some
crows in captivity have learned
something like a hundred words it's
absolutely
incredible
oh god what the heck security cameras
have given us many great gifts
she's not convinced
wow
i mean birds are scary you can't help
but squeal in a bird even when it's a
little bird
[Music]
okay so the crow's giving warning sounds
there almost all birds before they
attack give some sort of sign that
they're going to attack
and then it swoops
and then makes more aggressive
vocalizations so it's likely that it
doesn't like that female for some reason
maybe it's got young maybe that that
female human
disturbed the young
one of the reasons that crows are so
successful in towns and cities is that
they're really observant and they can
differentiate between individual human
faces so if she uh committed a sin
against the crow two years ago it's
likely that it would remember who she is
and potentially act aggressively or at
least let everyone else know in the area
that you're a threat so yeah
don't cross a crowd
[Music]
[Laughter]
do it again
the carrion crow which is all black
mostly lives in western europe and then
there's the hooded crow which sort of
looks as if it's got a little jumper on
that's gray that lives mostly in eastern
europe
he looks just like he's snowboarding
he's so cute
there's something that this crow is
getting out of this activity whether
that be just a pure physical feeling
that it's enjoying or whether it's
trying to break open the object there's
a billion things that could be going on
they do all sorts of
weird and interesting playful behaviors
that help them explore their world
okay
crow in the middle of the road
up with a hedgehog
that's
amazing
[Music]
so a hedgehog its primary form of
defense is to pretend to be a prickly
rock and that's what it was doing all
the way across the road and the crow
seemed to be
helping it across the road crows are
able to form attachments to other
beings and objects outside of their own
species
crows also taunt other animals they can
make fun they can play sort of hide and
seek but one of the reasons that crows
have done so well living close to humans
is that they are scavengers and they'll
happily eat roadkill which this hedgehog
was very close to becoming so it could
be possible that it's helping across the
road or the crow could just be being a
jerk
[Laughter]
entirely possible
ah
here we go
this is cool
i think that this is in japan
there's cash putting my nut on the road
so crows have been known to cash food so
that means they put it in little hidey
holes around so this nut may have been
one that this crow saved away for when
it was cold with all the snow
but to get into it he doesn't have one
of those beaks like a cocky does that
enables them to rip through husks and
nuts and things like that so what he's
trying to do is get a car to crack the
nut for him
or her
here we go
did it work
yep yep got a bit of nut
[Music]
they found that they do it close to
traffic signals so that the cars will
actually slow down a bit and that gives
the crow more of an opportunity to
escape and not get hit so these guys are
super smart they're getting our vehicles
to do their work for them and on top of
that putting a safety net in place to
make sure that they don't get smacked
no so there you have it crows aren't
scary in fact they're some of the most
quick-witted and intelligent creatures
that we have on this planet so next time
you see a crow in the street make sure
you say hello it'd be rude not to hello
[Music]
animals are facing shrinking habitats
out there in the wild and that means
they're coming closer and closer to
where we live in the cities the ones
that do thrive have proved that they're
street smart resourceful and willing to
take a risk and you know i think that we
need to give them some space we need to
live with these animals instead of
against them the biggest challenge
really will probably be admitting that
we might not be the smartest animal on
the block
hey thanks for watching i also host a
show called catalyst which is all about
science in australia you can watch it
here
and remember to hit subscribe and like
and the bell button because abc science
uploads videos every single week see you
later